you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news on today's programme
fossil fuel companies suing governments
for more than 18 billion dollars after
action against climate change threatens
profits
indonesia's president found guilty of
failing its citizens on their rights to
clean air
and a new report finds the covet 19
pandemic did not slow the advance of
climate change
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and we challenge those who are coming up
with the solutions
now governments around the world are now
in a race to tackle climate change with
an ever increasing warning that earth
will soon reach a tipping point with
irreversible impacts but now sky news
can exclusively reveal five big
companies are suing governments for 18
billion us dollars that's around 13
billion pounds for a possible loss of
earnings due to climate action where we
can bring in our climate change
correspondent hannah thomas peter who
has this story and just walk us through
what's what's happening hannah well
these fossil fuel companies these energy
companies are using an illegal process
that allows commercial entities to sue
governments under international laws
that govern trade arrangements and
treaties and agreements and they are big
energy companies we're talking about
rock copper and ascent to british
companies tc energy energy based in
canada and rwe and juniper both of
germany and the sums are whopping aren't
they 18 billion us dollars and to give
you some context
that's nearly a quarter of the entire
pledged climate funding amount from rich
nations to poor nations as it currently
stands yeah it's astonishing that's the
aggregate picture what are some of the
specifics of these individual lawsuits
well they're all different we've got
rockhopper so in the italian government
for 325 million dollars for offshore
drilling being banned near the coast
ascent suing slovenia for 118 million
for a fracking dispute and assessments
on environmental impacts you've got tc
energy suing the us government for 15
billion us dollars over the cancellation
of the keystone xl pipeline and then
you've got rwe and juniper suing the
dutch government for 1.6 billion and 1
billion each over the dutch government's
move away from coal i know you've
contacted these companies what have they
had to say well they have all said it is
our right to try and protect our profits
when we feel we have been wronged under
the laws that govern international
treaties and that is what we are going
to do we make no apology for it but
campaigners say that this has a chilling
effect on legislation to tackle climate
change and that fossil fuel companies
who have caused the climate crisis
should be paying for it not asking for
pay outs and what are the chances that
the governments will have to pay this
compensation well there's some precedent
uh in 2019 one of these international
trade dispute agreement or settlement
courts ruled against the government of
pakistan and said that it had to pay out
some six billion dollars a lot of money
for that nation to a copper mine company
over a dispute that arose over licenses
to mine in the region okay so certainly
one to watch hannah thank you
well later in the show we'll be
discussing whether governments should be
responsible for compensating the jobs
and businesses lost because of climate
policies plus the big issues expected at
cop 26 u.n climate summit and whether it
should go ahead at all today i'm joined
by climate change committee member jen
allen and the director of power shift
africa mohammad ado that is coming up
for you in just a few moments
meanwhile in some of today's other
climate news and the united nations said
that the world is likely to miss its
climate targets despite the pause in
emissions during the pandemic the united
in science report has found that fossil
fuel emission levels are now back to
2019 levels or even higher the un
secretary general said that this is a
critical year for climate action and
that all countries need to commit to net
zero by 2050.
and high court has ruled that the
environmental agency must do more to
protect a five-year-old boy from
landfill fumes that risk shortening his
life matthew richards was born with a
chronic lung disease
and his lawyers have argued that
hydrogen sulfide gas from wally's quarry
in staffordshire has worsened his
condition matthew's mother rebecca curry
said that she was overwhelmed by the
judge's decision
and the co-founder of apple is launching
a company to clean up space debris yes
that's right steve wozniak has founded
privateer which is being described as a
satellite company that's focused on
monitoring and cleaning up objects in
space the european space agency
estimates there are more than 170
million objects in the earth's orbit
now the indonesian president and six
other of his government officials have
been found guilty of failing to tackle
air pollution in the country 32 people
filed a lawsuit that includes taxi
drivers parents and environmental
campaigners sky's southeast asia
correspondent siobhan robbins reports
welcome to jakarta a city which
frequently tops the poles of the most
polluted air in the world
pollution which 32 residents took the
indonesian president and six top
officials to court over and won this is
a people's victory for us we are
very happy that there is
now a chance
for
uh improvement of living quality
starting with air quality in jakarta
judges today found the president three
ministers and three governors guilty of
environmental negligence for failing to
tackle the capital's chronic pollution
small gun fumes which campaigners claim
have cost thousands of lives and
billions of dollars
controlling emissions from industry and
cars in jakarta and protecting health
with clear air quality standards are
among the changes ordered
it's quite relieved for us
uh is i think it's a good start a good
beginning uh for air quality improvement
especially in jakarta and i do i do wish
that the government will take immediate
action to come to make out the
rules or decisions into
realization
but the fight isn't over
the politicians may still appeal
and unclogging this congested city for
good will take much more than political
will
siobhan robbins sky news
well all of that pollution in indonesia
is adding of course to the total global
co2 emissions which you can see here on
our data dashboard it also shows you the
estimated time before we get to that
critical one and a half degree rise
thought of being as the tipping point
and you can see here we are at 1.2 and
crucially that number is ticking up all
the time even as we speak well if we
look at the top of the data dashboard
there you can see the real-time power
mix to generate electricity here in the
uk at the moment coming 55 from fossil
fuels 29
from renewable sources
now the archbishop of canterbury is
urging the global community to come
together to address the climate crisis
justin welby had issued a joint message
with the pope and the head of the
orthodox church the head of the cop 26
conference that's due to be held in
glasgow in november the archbishop says
everyone has a role to play in the fight
against climate change
it's never happened in history that the
three of issued a joint statement and
that's to say that this is urgent
it's really important and it's for
individuals
for companies and institutions and for
governments
it can't be left to government or left
to companies or left to individuals
well do stay with us because we're going
to have more on that very topic after
the break i'm going to be joined by
climate change committee member jen
allen and the director of power shift
africa mohamed ado we're going to be
discussing whether or not governments
should have to compensate businesses
that have been affected by climate
policies as well as looking at cop 26
and if that climate summit can be
successful and some say perhaps we
shouldn't be going ahead with it at all
do stay with us
[Music]
i'm adam parsons i'm skye's europe
correspondent based here in brussels
more flares going off a volley of rocks
bubbles have been pulled up
out and are being used as missiles of
hell
at these police
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
we aim to be the best and most trusted
place for news
we have now left italy and entered
france nobody's asked to check our
identity
made by people who dare to challenge
nice to see you again mr barney
why committing you
fishing does have the potential to
stymie an enormous economic deal
what strikes you when you come to this
glacier is not just the way in which the
environment is changing but the speed at
which those changes are happening
it's uh devastating actually
[Music]
[Applause]
i'm tom cheshire and i'm skye's asia
correspondent based here in beijing
[Music]
it was my vision to come and protect
regulation future
[Music]
animals like lion can enter into bomas
they kill their livestocks and this
leads to human wildlife country
[Music]
did you know if you use less energy you
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the lights yep
a band of rain in the west will very
slowly move eastwards on friday much of
scotland northern ireland and the
republic will be cloudy with outbreaks
of rain heavy at times
england and wheels will be largely dry
with some warm sunny spells
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from 1 being low to 10 being very
high air pollution levels remain low on
friday as the rain and brisk winds
pushing east prevent the build-up of
pollutants
the air quality report sponsored by
philips air purifiers
hello again and welcome back to the
daily climate show here on sky news
we're getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day we've got the
climate change committee member jen
allen and also director of power shift
africa muhammad and a very good evening
to both of you well first off we are now
less than two months away from cop 26
climate summit in glasgow but there are
still very many questions about whether
it should even be going ahead because of
the ongoing pandemic and of course the
impact that it will have that it could
have on some of the world's developing
countries that are being severely
impacted by climate change i just want
to ask
both of you and coming to you jen first
i know that you're you're a pro of these
summits aren't you i think you've been
to nine already are we ready for glasgow
you know it's impossible to tell the uk
wants to host a business as usual huge
global event in times that are anything
but usual
uh the problem is that a lot of
countries are saying they can't come
between travel restrictions vaccine
inequities the added cost of
self-isolating for example
so the those most affected by climate
change are the least able to actively
participate in this comp so so in your
mind
is that
reason to postpone
yeah
it's this is a really high risk strategy
to hold this now
all the other major u.n meetings related
to the environment and even some others
they've all been postponed to 2022 at
least
so we're holding this one now and i
don't see the benefits of postponing it
or upholding it now versus postponing it
what we need is action that's already
coming through pledges we need added
finance
and we don't need people to show up in
glasgow to make those pledges or make
those announcements they can do it from
home
mohammed let's bring you in here i know
you have
originally called for it to be postponed
it's not going to happen is it i mean do
you think that it could do more harm
than it does good if it goes ahead
i'm afraid if the uk government cannot
hold a safe and accessible summit then
they will have to consider postponing it
the promise to vaccinate delegates you
know by the beginning of september but
we're still waiting i'm on the list for
a uk vaccine many civil society
delegates have already cancelled their
trips meaning
many important voices from the front
lines of the climate crisis will be
present in glasgow in paso accommodation
is also hugely expensive you know travel
goods remain disrupted and we also
understand now that coveted rates are
actually higher in scotland than in many
red leased countries
so i wanted us to have a safe summit
more than anyone but the idea of
traveling to glasgow in november with
covered rates spiking scary
and jen
you could see a scenario where some of
the delegates from some of these
countries they could be joining
virtually if not they're
in person you you don't think that
that's
gonna work by the sounds of it because
what people often say about these
summits is that the real agreements the
real sort of broker deals are made in
face-to-face sort of on the sidelines
conversations
yeah i can't count the number of times
that the last sort of piece of the
solution or of the agreed outcome
arrives in a huddle of 50 people on the
floor of plenary at 3 o'clock in the
morning
you can't do that virtually and as far
as i know the uk hasn't made any
provisions for virtual participation in
the actual negotiations
well that's troublesome isn't it um one
of the big pieces that needs to be put
in place and it was pledged ages ago
wasn't it i think copenhagen was this
hundred billion dollars a year financing
for developing countries to be able to
meet some of these climate goals it
hasn't materialized how optimistic are
you muhammad that that will get
something over the line
i think hopefully the world can learn
from the mistakes that we've made with
the
coveted vaccine rollout
the fact that vaccines haven't been
distributed fairly around the world has
allowed you know variants like delta to
actually emerge
uh you know who knows what's going to
happen in the future the fortunate thing
with climate and and there are a lot of
parallels i think between climate and
covet uh is that in the case of climate
and particularly climate uh finance you
know we've been negotiating this for
danke years you know the ritual led by
the us but also including every other
rich nation uh promised 10 years ago to
provide 100 billion to some of the most
vulnerable countries in the developing
world
that hasn't materialized and and now we
are in 2021 and so what we're looking
for and and starting actually with this
week uh un general assembly is for the
u.s particularly given the years we've
lost under the trump administration
forbidden to step up and actually
deliver the promise that obama made in
2009 towards supporting the vulnerable
countries i think between them the rich
world can actually mobilize more than
100 billion to support the much needed
you know mitigation actions but also
adaptation actions in the developing
countries i think we are much behind in
terms of delivering solidarity
to some of the most
vulnerable countries and these things
needs to be addressed uh before glasgow
so he doesn't really need to wait for
glasgow and the same goes for adaptation
support but also dealing with some of
the losses and damages that we can no
longer be able to adapt to these are
things that have been on the agenda for
the cup and and they don't have to wait
actually for glasgow they can start
making some of those things happen even
before we get together and is that not a
powerful argument for going ahead with
cop2626 at its intended
date because then you've got a hard stop
so you've got something that you're
working towards the eyes of the world
are going to be on that summit and you
might well get those climate pledges
that climate finance pledges over the
line more countries to commit if they
know that they have that hard date to
work towards
it's this strange irony we don't need
cop for climate action we need countries
to pledge set targets and deliver on
promises like finance
but
having these types of deadlines having
media attention focused on this issue
for two weeks having civil society
pushing for action
that helps and so even though it's not
an actual function or purpose of cop
one of the things that it does do is
galvanize attention and pressure
governments it's sad that we need this
it said we need that kind of pressure
but it is one of the things that cop can
do even though it shouldn't be necessary
for countries and governments to do the
right thing okay all right well you hope
to be positively surprised um i'm i'm
presuming from your 10th uh un summit
there well let's move on to look at the
topic that we were discussing earlier
with hannah thomas peter in the show
about those five companies who are suing
governments around the world for a
potential loss of profit because of
climate action policies so should
governments be responsible for
compensating loss of businesses or even
even jobs and what do you think about
this mohamed i mean energy companies
suing
governments for the damage that
their policies are having on their
bottom line they've got a point
no actually they don't energy companies
suing governments for enacting climate
policies is like a drug dealer in a
former addict for choosing to quit for
example heroin it's just ridiculous
we've got ourselves addicted to fossil
fuels and if we don't stop this dirty
habit it will kill us
you know rewarding companies that have
got us into this mess is absurd
i think instead what we need to see is
governments and especially governments
uh you know in climate vulnerable
countries which we should be suing these
companies for reparations for causing
the climate crisis in the first place
not these companies at all but you've
also got to consider haven't you jen the
pretty ruinous impact that when a
government decides to put an industry
into managed decline the impact that
that has on on the regions that were
dependent on that particular industry we
saw it didn't we in the 80s under
margaret thatcher's move to to to um
to remove manufacturing basically from
from our economy
government should support workers that's
not the same as supporting companies i
mean i'm sitting in wales we know what
an unjust transition looks like when an
industry collapses and there's no plan
so we need a plan for a just transition
that can involve retraining that can
involve some safety nets to make sure
that workers can have high quality jobs
that help climate proof the future
but i mean fossil fuel companies are the
most profitable companies on the planet
and they already get taxpayer money
through subsidies
they don't need more of our money but
the workers might need help and probably
will need help in finding high quality
jobs of the future yeah i mean
retraining re-skilling is going to be
essential would you agree with that
mohammed
yes i think we need a just transition to
environmentally sustainable economies
and societies
at the end of the day i think we need to
tackle environmental social and economic
problems in a coherent and integrated
manner i think a just transition of the
workforce and also creating decent work
but also quality jobs i think is crucial
so that we can be able to ensure public
support for the long term emissions
reductions and climate resilient
development we want at the end of the
day what we're all working towards is
actually delivering a healthy
environment for all of us and if the
process is going to require that we
actually transition away from high
carbon jobs i think what we need to
ensure is actually participatory and
representative processes
where we have social dialogues with
workers and and we can actually be able
to assure them that they won't lose in
the transition in fact they will gain
and will have more jobs going around
okay well we are out of time i'm afraid
it's fascinating talking to both of you
hearing your perspective sir muhammad
adu and jen allen thank you very much
indeed for your time on sky news this
evening well that is everything from us
for today joining me on the show
tomorrow to discuss all of the big
issues will be the honorary president of
the black environment network judy
linguang and business greens
editor-in-chief james murray but do stay
tuned for now coming up on sky news
tonight scotland and northern ireland
call for military assistance at nhs
hospitals i'll be plenty more on that uh
for you so do stay tuned for sky news
tonight in the meantime thank you for
watching the daily climate show hope to
see you again at the same time tomorrow
evening good night
[Music]